[Música]
el remake de resident evil 2 tuvo el
éxito asombroso y de esperarse es un
juegazo porque además de ser alabado por
los jugadores y las críticas el juego
por lo que a mí respecta ha superado el
original con tanto éxito de este remake
hay dos cosas seguras en este momento la
primera es que segurísimo que ahora se
está hablando en el remake del reciente
boom 3 de messis porque a ver si jugaste
los originales sabrás que el 2 y el 3 se
llevan a cabo casi en los mismos
escenarios agregando muy pocas cosas
nuevas así que básicamente con la gran
mayoría de mapas ya hechos en el remake
del 2 el trabajo para la reintegración y
bud 3 está bastante adelantado no además
de que los remakes del 1 y el 2 tuvieron
mucho éxito así que seguro ahora irán
por el 3 la segunda cosa segura es que
reside nivel 8 está en camino tal vez
hace un tiempo rossini bull perdió el
camino y su futuro algo incierto pero
con sus dos últimos juegos siendo muy
buenos y queridos tanto por los
jugadores como por la crítica eso es que
van a sacar una continuación a la saga
pero lo que vamos a ver en este vídeo es
lo que se sabe de momento tanto el
remake del reciente boom 3 como después
en el ebook 8 bueno comencemos por los
datos medio confirmados nueva veréis que
en twitter existe una cuenta llamada y
volvía que es una cuenta que filtró en
su momento bastantes detalles del remake
del recinto
2 así que es una cuenta que ya nos ha
traído filtraciones de otros juegos vale
obviamente no es una fuente oficial pero
es bastante confiable esta cuenta ahora
nos trae detalles pequeños tanto el
remake del 3 como el reciente 8 a
inicios de este año nos traban la
información de que se está considerando
si el siguiente juego de la saga es
decir el recién el 8 debería ser una
secuela o una spin-off y sobre todo que
ya se había decidido en cap con que el
juego tendría el enfoque de tercera
persona que ha ido al éxito del remake
del segundo juego a varias personas yo
incluido nos había gustado mucho el
cambio primera persona el séptimo juego
y por lo menos a mí me parece un juegazo
y me preguntaba seguirían con la
perspectiva en primera persona o la
cambiarían pero bueno el cambio de nuevo
a tercera persona no me molesta está
bien
luego de esto aseguró que resten v8 no
será lanzado antes del remake el 3 o sea
que antes de la salida del 8 tendremos
el remake de némesis ya es bastante
entendible capcom quiere tiempo para
pulir bien el juego y no volverá a
cagarla comer el 5 o el 6 así que por
ahora seguirán teniendo contentos a los
fans con el remake del 3 mientras
trabajan en el 8 y eso me parece una
buena decisión por parte de capcom y
algo bueno que mencionó es que no bien
planes para hacer remakes ni nada con
ninguno de los demás títulos con me
parece genial sería algo innecesario lo
que quiere decir básicamente es que
capcom se está enfocando actualmente en
sólo dos juegos el remake del 3 y el
resto y butt
algo interesante que la cuenta de
'twitter' filtro es que por lo que se
sabe de ración y but 8 tomará lugar en
una isla abandonada donde se encontrará
un laboratorio secreto y la historia
esta obra trata de descubrir la verdad
sobre evelyn y otras armas biológicas y
es que si se acuerdan en el recién nivel
7 el villano final era esta niña evelyn
que fue la que infectó con el virus de
los baker y creó a los moldes pero no
sabemos casi nada de ella lo que sabemos
es muy poca cosa y al parecer en
rescindido 8 ya sabremos quién carajos
acb
[Música]
lo último que la cuenta puede compartir
con nosotros es que el juego tomara
bastantes conceptos prestados de
'resident evil' 3.5 como las
alucinaciones y cosas así para los que
no lo sepan el racing y boot 3.5 es la
versión beta de reset y wood 4 donde
originalmente se pensaba seguir con la
temática del horror y hacer que el lyon
además de zombies se atentará
alucinaciones cosas así y por lo que
parece el recién tivo 8 tendrá conceptos
bastante parecidos
vamos a hacer un resumen de lo que se
sabe hasta ahora por parte del reciente
8 sólo se sabe por el momento que tendrá
un enfoque en tercera persona que se
tardará bastante probablemente llegando
para nueva generación de consolas lo
cual me parece bien de hecho y sobre la
historia lo que se sabe hasta el momento
es que tomará lugar en una isla
abandonada con un laboratorio secreto en
donde tendremos que adentrarnos para
revelar los secretos detrás de la
creación de evelyn y otras armas
biológicas enfrentándonos a una gran
cantidad de enemigos y como edición
tendremos alucinaciones que nos harán
dudar sobre qué es real y qué no y por
último la razón por la cual recién y bud
8 se tardará tanto es porque el juego se
ha hecho con una nueva acción del motor
gráfico que ya nos han dado últimamente
el versión en chino
este motor gráfico se usó para el
residuo el 7 el remake del 2 y para el
de jml hay 35 por lo cual capcom quiere
mejorar ese motor gráfico para su nueva
entrega razón por la cual llegará
probablemente hasta la próxima
generación de consolas
por el momento eso es todo lo que se
sabe el recién nivel 8 sobre el
realmente el 3 sólo sabemos que se
llamará recién el 3 ya no tendrá némesis
en el título que el juego es algo
completamente distinto al original que
es una re imaginación del juego por así
decirlo también sabemos que
probablemente sea el último remake por
ahora ya que capcom ha dicho que no
quiere tocar ningún sentido en ninguno
de los demás juegos y por último y tal
vez más importante se rumora que la
fecha de lanzamiento de este remake será
en marzo del 2020
bueno yo estoy bastante cómodo con todos
estos rumores sabes si resultan ser
verdad sobre el remake del 3 no tengo
ninguna queja hasta ahora si lo hacen
igual de bien que el remake del 2 ya con
eso tendremos el remake que estamos
esperando y un juegazo así que por mí
está bien y sobre garcía nivel 8 pues a
mí personalmente me ha gustado más un
juego en primera persona pero bueno creo
que eso es lo de menos todos estos
conceptos de una isla abandonada
alucinaciones y sueltos y la historia de
evelyn donde la dejamos me parece muy
interesante y en serio bastante
emocionado por estos títulos espero que
las cosas en el desarrollo sigan muy
bien para estos dos juegos cabe decir
que todo esto no son nada más que
rumores
capcom ha guardado silencio sobre estos
juegos desde que lo único que tenemos es
esos rumores aunque como dije son de una
fuente bastante confiable pero sólo
espero que cap contraiga pronto alguna
noticia y ya sea mi twitter o aquí en
youtube iré informando si pasa algo
importante y ustedes qué opinan sobre
todo esto dejando sus opiniones en los
comentarios quiero saber lo que todos
piensan dejar un link en la descripción
del vídeo de la cuenta de twitter de
hibble bear que es quien nos trajo todas
estas filtraciones así que le agradezco
mucho a él